it was with a phone call that yair lapid
formally informed israel's president
reuben rivlin
that he made it barely an hour before
the deadline to form a government
expired the negotiations were long and
tough
but in the end lapid managed to couple
together the government for change
eight parties ranging from the left to
the far right
with little in common except the desire
to oust caretaker prime minister
benjamin netanyahu
and end two years of political
instability for now
the new government will first see
far-right yamina party leader naftali
bennett
as prime minister he is an advocate of
illegal settlements expansion and their
annexation
doja erlapid is the one that told the
president he had the monday to form the
coalition
he's not going to be the prime minister
for the at least
the next two years it's naftali bennett
who leads a much smaller
party but became some sort of a
kingsmaker going
to be the prime minister for the next uh
the next
the next two years so in many ways this
is the kind of the axis in the middle
the heart of of the government
and the relations between yair lapid and
bennett that so
in the past ups and downs are going to a
large extent
determine the stability of the
government
but the new coalition couldn't have come
together without the support from the
most
unlikely of political allies mansur
abbas
and his islamic united arab list
i just signed an agreement with yellow
peter and former government we've agreed
on many issues that will serve the
interest of arab society
and provide solutions to the urgent
problems arab society faces in various
fields
it's a first for palestinian israelis
even though abbas will not be part of
the government
accepting support from our best is a
thorny issue for naftali bennett
with far-right politicians already
decrying a government
that relies on the support of a
palestinian-israeli bloc
next step is a vote of confidence by the
knesset that should take
at least a week in the meantime benjamin
netanyahu
a formidable political survivor who's
also facing corruption charges
will do his best for the coalition to
break up
if not he will become a relentless
opposition leader
al-jazeera in west jerusalem
dove waxman is from the university of
southern california he says it's
extremely significant to have the united
arab list support
not since the uh rabin government of the
early 1990s has
an israeli government depended upon the
supporter of an arab party and in this
case
not just an arab party but an islamist
our party so i think it's a huge moment
in israeli politics and legitimizing
uh the participation of our political
parties
in israeli government and and therefore
making
uh the wider our community palestinian
citizens
of israel a legitimate player in israeli
politics this is something that should
have been done
long ago but i think it's one of the
most significant accomplishments of this
coalition
the political glue that holds it
together is netanyahu and their aversion
to netanyahu
he's going to be doing everything he can
in the next week to 10 days to law some
right-wing defectors to put as much
pressure
upon them so that they don't uh vote for
the uh this government in the vote
that's due to take place in the knesset
and then afterwards he's going to be
trying to
create as many difficulties uh to create
instability in this coalition
and he'll he'll do what he can and he'll
hope
that this government will fall soon and
then he'll be able to
come back to power in the fifth election
of course he still faces the threat of
his looming
uh corruption trial and so he still has
a very strong incentive
to try to get parliamentary immunity and
that means
trying to get back into the prime
minister's office if he does end up
having to leave next week